the most enchanting creature ladies and
gentlemen to present the awards for the
best short subjects two of the most
popular and decorous people on the
screen today miss Jennifer Jones in mr.
Rock Hudson
before you present the award I would
like not only to congratulate you on
your many fine performances but also on
your names they have the most beautiful
names well and I'm what you might call a
named nut and I mean really seriously
like so many people you know like fans
of motion picture stars I'm enamored
with the wonderful graphic names that
motion picture stars have like Jennifer
Jones rods and Jack Lemmon
for the best achievement in live-action
subjects the nominees are a cherry tale
Norman McLaren producer City of Gold Tom
Daly producer foothold on Antarctica
James Carr producer Portugal Ben Sharpe
steam producer and the [ __ ] hound
Larry Larry Landsberg producer and the
winner is Birds anonymous Edward saucer
there's just a little slip I'm accepting
this Oscar the name of effort stalls her
for the best cartoon of the year called
burns anonymous and I want to pay my
tribute to Friz Freleng the director
picture Warren Coughlin story man and
about a hundred wonderful town of the
people at Warner Brothers cartoons
thanks
for the best achievement and cartoon
short subjects the nominees are birds
anonymous Edwards tells our producer one
droopy night william hanna and joseph
barbera producers Tabasco Road
Edward sells our producer trees and
Jamaica daddy
Stephen Basu Stowe producer the truth
about Mother Goose Walt Disney producer
and the winner is the [ __ ] hound
thank you very much